les gens de mon pays ce sens gens de
parole et jean de causerie qui parle
pour s'entendre et parle pour parler il
faut les écouter c'est plus que tous les
hommages ce qui le rendrait ressemble
c'est que vous tous à votre manière de
continuer son combat coin qui est des
plus justes plus fort oui les québécois
font quelque chose comme un grand peuple
et pernal en aura été à la hauteur ce
peuple qu'il a émis six national loin en
loin de celui jeu d'isère où vous vous
entêtez devant le dessin qui vient de
s'achever
il convient de s'incliner avec le
respect dû à un homme d'honneur et la
conviction infidèle et valeureux
combattants
[Musique]
josé sur les perrons des portes et de
chaque côté des crayons des clôtures je
vous le match 3e rue jogues c'est mieux
vaut chemin à dieu si la mécanique
revers ne doutant il est question nous
vend du vent debout reposer en baisse
mon rêve
atrium hier à notre cours de gestion
internationale vous nous avez manqué
monsieur le professeur bois dur si des
cantonales
une seconde attendait oui bernard tu as
laissé quelque chose qui résonne dans la
marche de notre humanité et de notre
destin avec des séries comme maintenant
le plus grand de ces droits est de
savoir que nous devons le québec thème
merci a bientot mon frère je vous
entends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous entends rouler
joe dante
dans ma gueule
cognet de ma mère
je vous entends penser comme un glaçon
des banques
je vous entends de ma
les deux
[Musique]